finalmente el terremoto político en
Italia Se ha producido Georgia meloni la
candidata del partido fratelli de Italia
ganó las elecciones si hace tan solo
cuatro años en las elecciones del 2018
su partido consiguió el
4,4% de los votos en esta ocasión han
obtenido el apoyo de casi el 26% de los
votantes
[Música]
hablamos de un enorme despegue político
para un partido fundado en el año 2012
un resultado que les ha convertido en
los líderes de la coalición de Centro
derecha que ahora controla Italia el
partido de melón y se presentó a las
elecciones en Alianza con la liga de
salvini y Forza Italia de berlusconi
entre los Tres hicieron con casi el 60%
de los escaños de la cámara de diputados
y del senado
y sabéis que este cambio de rumbo en la
tercera mayor economía de la Unión
Europea está dando mucho de que hablar
sobre todo porque según se dice con la
elección de melón y Italia se ha echado
en manos de la extrema derecha y la
pregunta es es esto cierto en este vídeo
os vamos a contar con todo detalle las
claves de la victoria de meloni y vamos
a responder a una pregunta clave qué
podemos esperar ahora de Italia así que
sin más preámbulos arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Sí a la familia natural no a los lobbys
el gbt si a la identidad sexual No a la
ideología de género si a la cultura de
la vida no el Abismo de la muerte si el
universalidad de la cruz no la violencia
es la misa si la fronteras seguras no la
inmigración masiva si el trabajo en
nuestro ciudadanos no los grandes
finanzas internacionales Sí a la
soberanía de los pueblos no los
burócratas de Bruselas Y si a nuestra
civilización y no a quienes quieren
destruirlo como os podéis imaginar estas
y otras declaraciones han hecho que
Georgia meloni se gane una fama de Ultra
Y es que no se trata solo de lo que dice
sino también de cómo lo dicen si lo
pensáis la intención es hacer un
discurso claramente
lista ahora bien aunque esto de por sí
no parezca nada bueno no nos basta para
tener una radiografía completa de melón
Y si Queremos saber por qué ha ganado Y
qué podemos esperar ahora tenemos que ir
más allá entre otras cosas porque este
nuevo fenómeno político y social no es
lo que podríamos calificar como outsider
de la política ni tampoco una Recién
llegada No al contrario melón y sabe muy
bien lo que hace incluso ha llegado a
ocupar puestos de responsabilidad
ejecutiva
melón y de adolescente formó parte de
movimientos políticos estudiantiles
ligados al post fascismo italiano fue
elegida diputada por primera vez en el
año 2006 por el partido Alianza nacional
en 2008 y con solo 31 años Fue nombrada
ministra de juventud por Silvio
berlusconi convirtiéndose así en la
ministra más joven de toda la historia
del país ocupó ese cargo hasta finales
del 2011 cuando overlusconi fue forzado
a dimitir en medio de una enorme crisis
económica política y social Un año más
tarde melón y fundó su propio partido
de Italia un partido con posiciones más
escoradas a la derecha que la forcha
Italia de berlusconi y con mucha
similitudes ideológicas con las lega de
Mateos albini incluido el euro
escepticismo que el partido ha mostrado
hasta hace relativamente poco tiempo
Y tal vez por eso si algo está claro es
que esta Victoria no ha sentado nada
pero que nada bien en el establishment
de Bruselas
Y es que veréis a nivel europeo meloni y
su partido fratelli forman parte del
partido de los conservadores y
reformistas europeos que es la formación
que agrupa a partidos como el polaco ley
y Justicia el pis Box en España o los
demócratas de Suecia Y eso explica que
en cierto modo en Bruselas tengan pavor
a que la tercera mayor economía de la
unión puede adoptar una posición tan
hostil o desobediente como las que
mantienen países como Hungría o Polonia
algo que ha hecho saltar todas las
alarmas y desatado la furia de muchos
medios de comunicación lo que muchos
calificarían como la apisonadora
mediática Georgia meloni y el retorno
del fascismo como Italia ha llegado a
esto el comodín de extrema derecha
Giorgia al meloni aprovecha el deseo de
los italianos de un cambio radical
Georgia meloni es un peligro para Italia
y para el resto de Europa melón y Silva
sus ancestros políticos neofacistas con
el eslogan de La era de Mussolini Dios
Patria y familia como veis son muchos
los que han presentado la victoria de
Georgia meloni como una especie de
Victoria del Neo fascismo la llegada al
poder de la extrema derecha y claro con
semejante percal puede que muchos os
estáis haciendo una pregunta es
realmente Georgia melón y una fascista
suponeso victoria una amenaza para la
democracia Cuáles son exactamente sus
propuestas y sus compromisos políticos
Qué puede suponer su Victoria para el
país de Valentino Rossi Enzo Ferrari o
Giorgio Armani Pues bien todo esto y más
lo vamos a responder a continuación
atentos
[Música]
una herencia complicada
queridos amigos amigas de visualpolitik
no nos engañemos las cosas no suceden
por nada y la lección de melón y no fue
por casualidad Los italianos han tenido
sus motivos
[Música]
Italia es uno de los países que peor
desempeño económico han tenido de todo
el mundo desarrollado en las últimas dos
décadas en términos reales el pib Per
cápita fue en 2019 inferior al del año
2000 la deuda pública la quinta mayor de
todo el mundo se sitúa en torno al 145%
del pib el segundo ratio más alto del
eurozona tan solo después de Grecia
además la todavía poca integración
relativa de la mujer en el mundo laboral
y el paro juvenil que se mantiene por
encima del 20%. está estresando la
economía de muchas familias a medida que
la inflación está repuntando con fuerza
y para colmo todo esto está aderezado
con un déficit de más del 5%. un
crecimiento anémico y unas previsiones
de futuro francamente malas
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas Próximamente os
daremos muchos más detalles sobre la
situación de la economía italiana en
nuestro canal hermano visual económico
un momento aún no conoces visual
economic no me lo puedo creer Échale un
vistazo porque si te ha gustado el
politik vas a disfrutar también este
nuevo canal os dejo el enlace abajo en
los comentarios
[Música]
El caso es que de no cambiar las cosas
Italia se dirige a toda velocidad hacia
una quiebra prácticamente asegurada y de
momento la experiencia que tienen los
italianos Es que hace ya muchos años Que
su nivel de vida dejó de mejorar Así que
para salir del pozo Italia necesita una
auténtica Revolución económica
regulatoria y fiscal entre otras cosas
hará falta a cometer una fuerte
contención del gasto porque básicamente
el país está quedando sin dinero hoy por
hoy en términos netos el único actor que
compra deuda pública italiana es el
Banco Central europeo sin embargo este
cambio parece inviable en un país donde
la política hace aguas cada poco tiempo
Y es que a los malos datos económicos se
suma una enorme inestabilidad política
recordad que hablamos de un país que ha
tenido 70 gobiernos en los últimos 77
años y claro Así es que es imposible con
tanta volatilidad política no hay forma
de poner en marcha un plan de reformas a
medio y largo plazo y además tanto
vaivén ha causado un enorme y desengaño
entre los italianos que ven Como cada
año que pasa el país está peor Y peor en
Italia prácticamente en lo único que se
ponen de acuerdo los políticos es en
utilizar masivamente la enorme tarjeta
de crédito pública ya sabéis los votos
cuestan estos lo que explica el enorme
consenso que existe para revalorizar más
y más unas pensiones que ya se tragan
más del 16% de todo el pib nacional pero
queréis otro ejemplo más concreto y
reciente pues fijaos Italia se ha
gastado hasta la fecha más de 66 mil
millones de euros en ayudas para paliar
los efectos
crisis energética lo que puede estar
bien o mal Eso ya depende de cada uno
pero lo que parece claro es que dada las
circunstancias del país No puede ser su
única política Así que si tenemos todo
esto en cuenta si algo parece evidente
Es que la política económica será uno de
los mayores retos a los que se
enfrentará el gobierno de meloni y
también una de las claves que explica el
resultado electoral aunque no la única
la inmigración ilegal ha sido sin género
de dudas uno de los temas más calientes
de la política italiana Durante los
últimos años para que os hagáis una idea
desde el 2015 han llegado hasta Italia
750.000 inmigrantes ilegales tan solo en
agosto del 2022 llegaron a las costas
italianas más de 45.600 personas de
forma irregular y esto supuso Un aumento
del 40%, si lo comparamos con el año
anterior
y un dato curioso que explica algunas de
las posiciones clave de melón Y en este
campo de todas las personas que llegaron
ilegalmente a las costas italianas en
agosto del 2022 casi la mitad lo
hicieron a bordo de barcos de ongs o de
la propia Marina italiana Pues bien El
caso es que si metemos en una batidora
ingredientes como la falta de
oportunidades el mal desempeño económico
el pesimismo la inmigración o el aumento
de la violencia lo que tenemos es la
receta política que explica
perfectamente la victoria de meloni
digamos que los italianos se han cansado
de las palabras bonitas y le han dado el
gobierno a una fuerza política con un
discurso contundente y claro la cuestión
es que podemos esperar de este nuevo
fenómeno político que ha cautivado a los
italianos Pues bien veamoslo
el nacimiento de melonomics
a ver podríamos Definir la propuesta
económica de melón y como algo a medio
camino entre el proteccionismo y el
liberalismo económico si es que algo así
se puede compaginar y es que veréis me
explico en su agenda económica
patriótica hay medidas para todos los
gustos tenemos recetas populistas
nacionalistas proteccionistas y también
algunas más interesantes
por un lado melón y defiende establecer
medidas anti Libre Mercado para impedir
que las empresas extranjeras puedan
hacerse con participaciones mayoritarias
en activos y empresas italianas que sean
consideradas estratégicas un ejemplo de
ello es su oposición a la toma de
control de la aerolínea italiana y
tareways por parte de Air France también
quiere que el estado utilice entidades
financieras públicas Como por ejemplo la
caja de depósitos y préstamos para
controlar grandes empresas italianas
Este es el caso de Telecom Italia El
coloso de las telecomunicaciones que
melón y quiere volver a nacionalizar
para gestionarlo directamente
[Música]
terrorífico Aunque a ver siendo justos
un poco muy diferente a lo que vemos en
países como Francia Francia nacionaliza
la mayor eléctrica Europea y anticipa el
Inevitable regreso del Estado pero
sigamos
[Música]
una de las promesas estrella de meloni
ha sido su promesa de aprobar una rebaja
fiscal generalizada para familias y
empresas ahora bien la pregunta es cómo
puede el gobierno italiano aplicar
grandes rebajas Fiscales si tenemos en
cuenta el desastroso estado en el que se
encuentran las cuentas públicas y ahí un
importante cuestión que aún está por
resolver desde los círculos de meloni se
apunta a que una opción pasa por
cargarse la conocida como renta de
ciudadanía esta renta es una especie de
ingreso mínimo garantizado para
desempleados sin ingresos que impulsó el
movimiento 5 estrellas en la campaña
electoral del 2018 se trata de una ayuda
de entre 500 y 780 euros al mes que ha
sido muy popular en el sur de Italia
donde se concentra el 70% de los
beneficiarios El problema es que apenas
hablamos de 9 mil millones de euros Así
que esto no nos Resuelve la incógnita
sobre cómo financiar la rebaja fiscal
otra opción que se señala es lo que la
propia melonía bautizado como Bad fiscal
una especie de amnistía fiscal con la
que recaudar unos 30.000 millones de
euros en cinco años pero tampoco eso
parece suficiente porque no hablamos de
bajar unos cuantos impuestos
melón y se ha comprometido a impulsar
una medida que lleva ya más de 20 años
revoloteando en los debates políticos
pero que sin embargo nunca se ha puesto
en marcha hablamos del flag tags o tipo
impositivo único la idea consensuada en
el seno de la coalición electoral que ha
ganado las elecciones sería Establecer
un tipo impositivo único primero para
los autónomos que facturen hasta 100.000
euros y luego en fases posteriores
aplicarlo a los incrementos anuales de
la renta de todos los contribuyentes es
decir si consigues ganar más el primer
año tendrás recompensa fiscal Esta es la
promesa estrella en materia económica
una promesa que se complementaría con
fuertes beneficios para que Cuanto más
grande sea una familia menos impuestos
tenga que pagar ya sabéis Dios Patria y
familia Luego en materia de empresas el
equipo de melón y se ha comprometido a
impulsar fuertes deducciones Fiscales
para aquellas empresas que contraten más
trabajadores la idea el principio es que
quien más contraté menos pague
[Música]
en cualquier caso lo que todavía no está
nada Claro es cómo podrán financiar las
rebajas Fiscales y la implantación de
este flattacks Pero bueno eso que tiene
la política es más fácil prometer que
concretar ya veremos Cómo se desarrollan
los acontecimientos de momento para
terminar esta parte económica sin duda
alguna uno de los grandes quebraderos de
cabeza del nuevo gobierno se han
conocido como plan Nacional de
recuperación y resiliencia el pnr
[Música]
este plan es básicamente la hoja de ruta
de Italia para acceder a los fondos
europeos next generation un plan en el
que este país tiene asignados unos
200.000 millones de euros un plan que
centró mucha atención en la campaña
porque melón y ha insistido en cambiarlo
de arriba a abajo su objetivo es
utilizar estos fondos para llevar a cabo
grandes proyectos como el varias veces
cancelado puente del estrecho de messina
un puente que permitiría conectar la
Península italiana con sicilia sería el
puente colgante más largo del mundo
veremos Cómo se lo toman en Bruselas
pero amigos y amigas hasta aquí la parte
económica porque si algo está claro es
que las implicaciones de este fenómeno
van mucho más allá atentos
[Música]
y responsabilidad y responsable Manuel
macrón su novia a ver que llegaba
fastidio
energético con getafe
exponiéndose al caos migración en el
cual el chico habíamos
a la polaca o a la húngara
amigos hay una cosa que la vuelve loca
meloni esa es cargar contra el eje París
Berlín que es que maneja los hilos en
Europa Europa contra Europa nuestra
Europa que tiene raíces cristianas
grecorromanas contra la Europa de macron
y Merkel de esos que buscan darle
todavía más soberanía nacional a los
tecnócratas europeos Georgia meloni pero
hay que reconocer que con macrón con
macron tiene especial debilidad
[Música]
yo
cayendo laborales Bambi
Endo materia prima
para caminar el eje central y nuclear y
el 90 de nicherini vive electricidad
para elección y makro
es melón y una líder populista
seguramente es una política con
posiciones mucho más extremas de lo que
suele ser convencional no hay duda es
conservadora Pues sí desde luego
nacionalista también pero de ahí a
considerarla una amenaza para la
democracia hay un largo trecho pero
dicho esto irá a dar la similitudes
ideológicas que existen en muchos Campos
hay una pregunta que podemos hacernos es
mailor y más parecida al húngaro orbán o
se parece Más al polaco monabieski
Pues bien pongamos como ejemplo el
conflicto del momento el gran conflicto
de las últimas décadas atentos a estas
declaraciones
[Aplausos]
to Five for freedom simplificando yo
creo estoy convencida del hecho de que
la guerra en Ucrania es la punta del
iceberg de un conflicto cuyo objetivo es
la revisión del orden mundial si Ucrania
caes y occidente se debilita los grandes
vencedores del conflicto aparte de la
Rusia de Putin será la china de sillín
Georgia meloni lo siento por los que han
dicho que la victoria de meloni era la
victoria de Putin Puede que no nos guste
Pero puede que la realidad sea diferente
[Música]
Sí es así tanto melón y como su partido
para tele de Italia han sido muy claros
al manifestar su compromiso con la otan
y con la defensa de Ucrania y entre
otras cosas están a favor de incrementar
los envíos de armas aquí de hecho este
ha sido el eje y de su campaña electoral
en materia de política internacional y
el punto número uno del programa
electoral de la coalición y todo ello a
pesar de que salvini y berlusconi han
demostrado digamos unas posiciones
bastante equidistantes Y hasta
simpatizantes con Rusia 23 de septiembre
del 2022 verluscone dice que Putin
invadió Ucrania para poner a gente
decente en keef 1 de junio de 2022 el
italiano salvinini muy criticado por
conversaciones secretas con Rusia los
encuentros con el embajador serán
investigados por un comité parlamentario
ya lo veis a pesar de tener estos dos
compañeros de batalla melonia ha
conseguido imponer su visión brotan por
Ucrania y proestados Unidos luego en el
caso de la Unión Europea melonia ha sido
siempre fuertemente Euro escéptica y de
hecho llegó a pedir la de Italia de la
Unión Europea Aunque bueno seguro que lo
hizo sin pensar que eso conllevaría la
quiebra automática de un país que hoy
por hoy depende del Banco Central
europeo pero el caso es que ahora la ley
de fratelling se ha presentado con un
programa mucho más pragmático
[Música]
no está en condiciones de salir de la
Unión Europea y que necesitaba la ayuda
económica y la asistencia financiera de
las instituciones comunitarias para
evitar la quiebra por eso la política
italiana ha girado desde el ital exit
hasta una posición centrada en pedir
cambios en Bruselas en concreto la líder
italiana al igual que la posición del
gobierno polaco pasa porque la
construcción europea sea menos
centralizada y menos burocrática es
decir que los países mantengan mayores
cotas de autonomía y soberanía
[Música]
resumiendo que en materia de política
internacional No veremos grandes cambios
excepto algún que otro roce que Seguro
seguro se producirá con Bruselas algo
que en cualquier caso cada vez resulta
más habitual en los miembros de la unión
Pero quizás la cuestión más polémica
controvertida y delicada de este
programa político se ha su postura sobre
la inmigración ilegal algo que como ya
hemos dicho ha sido una de las grandes
bazas de su Victoria electoral ahora la
pregunta es qué propone exactamente la
líder de fratelli
Pues básicamente defiende tres ideas
clave por un lado quiere Establecer un
mecanismo que expulse de las aguas
territoriales italianas a los barcos que
transporten inmigrantes ilegales incluso
Aunque pertenezcan a una ong por otro
defiende establecer una red de hotspots
en el norte de África para que la
solicitudes de asilo se gestionen fuera
de la Unión Europea una red que ya
propone que este gestionada por la
propia Bruselas y En tercer lugar aboga
porque los permisos de residencia y
ciudadanía para extranjeros están
sometidos a criterios de selección en
función de las similitudes
socioculturales que tengan los
inmigrantes con Italia en otras palabras
quieren menos inmigrantes musulmanes y
más latinoamericanos cristianos Oye en
acciones
con la propia cultura
literalmente Moreno
solo cristiano somos
Venezuela dicho esto pasemos ya de lleno
al último punto de este vídeo la
política interna
melón y tiene un carácter fuertemente
conservador que defiende de que las
raíces judío cristianas como ella mismo
dice lleguen incluso a regir la política
social del estado meloni se opone el
aborto Aunque eso sí ha dicho que no lo
va a prohibir sino que su objetivo es
impulsar medidas para evitar que las
mujeres lleguen hasta ese extremo
también se opone al matrimonio
homosexual algo que en Italia todavía no
Es legal aunque se ha mostrado favorable
a mantener la unión civil de personas
homosexuales tal y como está así mismo
Está en contra de la gestación subrogada
y de la adopción por parte de parejas
del mismo sexo
[Música]
es decir no hablamos de ningún cambio
relevante respecto a la situación actual
de Italia a lo sumo puede que el
gobierno se parezca más al polaco Y eso
nos podrá gustar más nos podrá gustar
menos pero tanto en materia económica
como política como social nos esperan
grandes sobresaltos durante el gobierno
de meloni lo más atrevido de su política
y no nos engañemos probablemente no haya
grandes avances de hecho algunas voces
apuntan a que la líder de fratelli
podría incluso incluir perfiles
tecnócratas a su gobierno para calmar a
Bruselas y presentar al mundo una imagen
más moderada
Muchos medios nos han vendido que melón
y representa la llegada de la
ultraderecha y del fascismo al poder sin
embargo es muy probable que eso sea un
tanto exagerado bastante exagerado y ojo
que no hablamos de un tipo de política
que nos guste ni un pelo pero hay que
ser fieles a la realidad nos parecen sea
como sea lo que está claro es que Italia
se enfrenta a un futuro complicado muy
complicado y a tenor de la experiencia
veremos Cuánto dura este gobierno pero
llegas hasta aquí turno para ti crees
que el gobierno de meloni y de la
llamada coalición de Centro derecha
supondrá un giro una radicalización de
Italia existe tanto peligro para la
democracia y la libertad como pintan
algunos medios de comunicación déjanos
tu opinión aquí abajo en los comentarios
y si te ha gustado este vídeo No olvides
darle al botón de like y suscribirte a
nuestro canal Para no perderte ninguna
novedad una vez más gracias por estar
ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]